what three blue one brown has done for
mathematics is unsurpassed not only with
the channel but with the summer of math
exposition contest which for those of
you who are unfamiliar is less of a
contest and more of an ethos to create
mathematical explainer videos
collectively during the same time period
i'm a huge huge fan of grant sanderson
the person behind three blue one brown
and the summer of math exposition
contest and thought well since this
channel theories of everything is about
physics and consciousness studies why
not do a similar contest but on those
topics instead a few weeks ago i emailed
grant just to not step on any toes so to
speak and he said go for it so today i'm
announcing the physics and consciousness
explications contest essentially it's a
place and a period for you to submit
your video explainer of a physics
phenomenon or of a consciousness
phenomenon or theory we'll go into
exactly what that means shortly and
brilliant to similarly come on board
with one thousand dollars to give to
each one of the top five winners that is
five thousand divided among five i'll
make a video with the top explainer
videos of course that's extremely
subjective and so i'll be supplementing
that with a playlist inventorying each
of the entries so what's the point of
all of this well number one it's not to
have winners it's to have more
disquisitions on topics that don't have
readily digestible tutorials out there
at least not publicly number two it's to
give a nudge to you or to someone you
know who you want to share this with who
is on the perimeter of deciding to make
a video
but is unsure perhaps the scant
incentive of being recognized with views
or recognized financially with the prize
pushes you in the direction of making
content that you may not have otherwise
number three the top comments on the
three blue one brown youtube video about
the contest is something that i
resonated with blar goner this user said
that it's unfortunate that the more
advanced videos which explicitly assumed
some prerequisite knowledge got down
voted and flagged as being unclear not
explaining jargon etc despite such
entries indeed being allowed by the
general guidelines in the future
consider having different levels of
submission for example advanced the
point is i have also found that a large
segment of the youtube population is
starved for content for advanced content
perhaps at the graduate or upper year
undergraduate level however most of the
content out there is directed toward the
high school level the toe podcast at
least in some ways can be thought of as
speaking to that starved segment though
while in podcast form much can be
traversed quickly much concepts verbally
still plenty is lost because there
aren't equations and animations it would
be great if that lacuna was filled that
is more advanced graduate topics since
the lower year undergraduate topics seem
to get all the attention so for example
if you have a thesis or a capstone
project for your masters or your phd and
you'd like to distill it down to its
essence then communicate it via video
and submit let's get on to tips so
number one choose a video that you would
like to see created a video that you
wish existed and perhaps even in the
style that you wish existed number two
don't just use powerpoint slides and
talk through it okay so what are some
ideas of potential videos to be
submitted well firstly if you're unsure
join the discord the link will be in the
description as well as you can just
visit tinyurl.com
discord toe that is t-o-e but on to some
examples what is yang mills theory how
does the etia singer index theorem
relate to physics what is a lagrangian
manifold and why is the symplectic creed
that everything is a lagrangian some
manifold what's an euler class or if
you're daring what's the churn
gauss-bonnet's theorem's implications
for supersymmetry what is e8 as a lead
group and what's that's relation to the
e8 lattice or you can take some theory
of everything that exists so string
theory and explain some concept within
it or for example wolfram's physics
project and explain how black holes are
formed or the maximum quantum
entanglement speed or in loop quantum
cosmology perhaps you'd like to explain
what ashtakar variables are and why
they're useful what's a sigma model
what's the symplectic version of quantum
mechanics how do you formulate quantum
mechanics without complex numbers and
what are the tradeoffs and benefits now
on the consciousness side some example
videos would be to explain yoshibok's
computational model of consciousness now
hey good luck with that or to explain
bernardo castro's analytical idealism or
to explain why phi has anything to do
with consciousness in integrated
information theory or why it may not and
you can explain global neuronal
workspace theory what are the technical
problems perhaps epistemic perhaps
ontological with having neural
correlates of consciousness be an
explainer of consciousness how does
douglas hofsteder's strange loop concept
work and where does it fall short you
can even combine consciousness and
physics with an explainer of
orchestrated objective reduction that's
penrose's theory or perhaps you can
explain just an aspect of it that is
what is frolic resonance there was a
study recently that apparently shows
some limits of certain quantum theories
of consciousness well does it what are
the limitations of this study what is
conway's free will theorem it doesn't
have anything to do with free will what
is super determinism and now we're back
on the physics side sabine haasenfelder
is working assiduously on that so you're
welcome to email her and say hey would
it be okay if i took some voice clips of
yours from this time stamp and this time
stamp and added animations perhaps your
own narration some people in the toe
audience are studying neuroscience and
so if you want you can show how machine
learning is related to concepts in
consciousness or qualia or perception
because perhaps that's what you're
writing your phd thesis on feel free to
go ahead and make a video even if it
means that you're submitting to two
different places like your advisor
perhaps another contest that doesn't
matter to me in fact i encourage it
because it adds extra motivation i
should emphasize that you don't have to
submit an idea that incorporates both
physics and consciousness but instead
it's best to just focus on one of the
two that is make a physics submission or
make a consciousness submission as
generally those that try to combine both
tend to lack the rigor that we're aiming
for with pace one there are exceptions
of course
again if you're unsure if your idea for
your video fits then visit the discord
and ask that's tinyurl.com
toe okay so what are the rules well
number one you're allowed to submit to
multiple contests that is to say if
you're submitting to summer of math
exposition number two that doesn't
preclude you from submitting here as
well another rule is that you must make
your video public it can't be unlisted
because the primary point is to have
more commentary and explorations on
physics and consciousness both prevalent
and overt number three unlike the three
blue one brown video this is exclusive
to video content so no blog posts are
allowed number four is make sure that
you have one entry per group or per
individual and it also needs to be in
english another rule is to please use
the hashtag that's on screen in your
submission title and lastly the deadline
for submission is october 12th 2022 11
59 pm toronto time i don't want to be
kept too late past my bedtime now let's
get to what are some possible styles for
the videos so obviously you could do a
lecture with a blackboard and a tablet
that's not terribly engaging but perhaps
you can make it so there's animation
that's the three blue one brown style
that's extremely difficult but
wonderfully engaging number three you
can make it a documentary style so i'll
give some examples of those on screen
right now number four is you can make it
exploratory where you throw out ideas
it's you learning the topic you going
through a journey you're showing your
mistakes along the way open questions
you still have showing connections
between different fields and related
concepts it's not you as an expert it's
you as a student learning the topic
another style is to take some work that
exists and remix it with the original
creator's permission of course so for
example richard borchard's leech lattice
explanation or donald hoffman here or
like i mentioned with sabine
haasenfelder and super determinism
another style is to take an article or a
paper that you want to learn and then
you go through it so for example the
papers that got written the fields metal
at least in part the jones polynomial
you go through it and then you explain
it maybe line by line or maybe paragraph
by paragraph or page by page or combine
it with animations or simply just remix
it with any of these styles okay so now
what are the criteria for winning
again please this is not about winning
this is simply to have more explications
out there however if you're interested
one of the criteria is to take something
that's traditionally complex and then
make it digestible so that is this ratio
between complexity and simplicity so for
example elucidating what yang mills
theory is rigorously is notoriously
difficult perhaps you can find some
analogies to make it more digestible
not exactly simple simple the incorrect
word number two it needs to be engaging
and entertaining and then number three
is that you keep in the rigor so no hand
waving no
if you're doing something regarding
consciousness no using the word quantum
as some let's say new age people may
incorrectly use the words that they
sound more scientific instead for this
contest please stick to equations
precision and logical rigor and when i
say rigor i mean a physicist rigor which
essentially is a mathematician's hand
wavy but you understand what i mean good
luck and again if you have questions go
to the discord which is linked below
tinyurl.com
discord t-o-e as well as it's in the
description for the rest of this video
i'll be going through some examples of
explications that exist that i think are
particularly wonderful
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you